الدفاع في تايوان
ان الجزيره يجب ان تكون في حاله تاهب هذا
العام تحسبا لما وصفه باي دخول مفاجئ
للجيش الصيني في مناطق قريبه من اراضيها
وردا على سؤال لاحد وابقى
رائعه لدخول مناطق قريبه من المجال الجوي
والبحري الاقليميه لتايوان مع تعزيز
الجزيره علاقاتها العسكريه مع الولايات
المتحده ووسط توترات عسكريه متزايده عبر
مضيق تايوان الحساس في غضون ذلك على الصين
رفع الميزانيه العسكريه الجديده لعام 2023
بمقدار عشر في المئه مقارنه بالعام
المنصرم جاء ذلك خلال افتتاح عمل الدوره
الرابعه عشره للمؤتمر الوطني
اكدت ان هذه الزياده في الميزانيه
العسكريه طفيفه وبانها لا تشكل تهديدا لاي
دوله اخرى بل هي ضروريه لتطوير قدرات
البلاديه الدفاعيه ومن المتوقع ان تستمر
اجتماعات مجلس النواب الشعب نحو اسبوع
تجري خلالها مناقشه ملف تايوان اضافه الى
وضع اهداف التنميه الاقتصاديه والاجتماعيه